Darius Rucker is opening up about living
under the shadow of systemic racism in
the US for his entire life the country
singer spoke candidly with today's Harry
Smith but how the death of George Floyd
is how the reinvigorated black lives
matter movement has influenced change in
his own life especially after having
three children watch what kids go do
this I think they just have that age not
where they have to look at it
I've lived with racism my whole life
made me really sit there go I just can't
keep living my life like everything's
okay because everything's not okay
Darius admits that he's already had
conversations about how to act around
police with his three kids and recalls
his only experience being pulled over
driving a nice car getting stopped you
know knowing you're not speeding or
anything she could stop of course when
they recognized me everything's cool you
know why they get stopped officer oh you
know you know it was it wasn't speeding
I know I wasn't doing that I get stopped
because I was a you know like kind of
expensive car okay but it's happened a
million times it's just so not right
it's not and the thing is it's not gonna
change until enough people say it's
wrong the hootie and the blowfish
frontman added that as a black artist
and a predominantly white music genre he
came to accept racism as a simple fact
of life and recalled being told during
radio station visits that his music
wouldn't be played because he's black
really you get the pony oh that's just
you know that's just how it is you know
when I was going to radio stations and
you got guys telling me we're not gonna
play you cuz you're a black guy okay
that's just the way it is but I can't
live like that anymore I can't just go
it's okay and go on my life and you know
let somebody say something I know she
they shouldn't say now the singer is
sensing some sort of change
like anything he's ever experienced
before so much of the country really
wants some kind of change don't know
what we're gonna do don't know how we're
gonna do it but they want some kind of
changing so for me it feels different
the help I'm right
last month in the days following the
death of George Floyd the country singer
posted a lengthy letter to social media
platforms where he shared that Floyd's
death breaks me down to my core and
promised that he would no longer
perpetuate the myth that things are okay
now just a few days after the country
singer appeared on today he took to
social media to break the news that he
and his wife Beth Leonard have decided
to part ways
the singer announced the divorce along
with a photo of himself and Beth at the
CMA Awards in 2017 writing Beth and I
would like to share that after much
reflection we have made the decision to
consciously uncouple we remain close
friends and parenting partners and
continue to be each other's biggest
cheerleaders our priority will always be
our beautiful family we have so much
love in our hearts for each other and
will continue to encourage growth and
expansion in one another please be kind
as we take on this journey and we thank
you for your love and support always the
couple tied the knot in 2000 and share
two kids 19 year old daughter Daniela
and 15 year old son Jack Darius's third
child 25 year old Carolyn is from a
previous relationship